first summit in a new era of our
partnership in new stage of our
partnership with the three of them we
have now Association agreements and
DSHEA signed partially implemented even
but also with the other three partners
we have increased and deepen our areas
of cooperation in many fields for the
benefits of our people both in the
European Union and in the partner
countries and I have to say that today
we get to the stage of the day to day
normal working relationship between
partners and for the Minsk we have a
main criteria close the border is draw
all the foreign troops make a ceasefire
withdraw heavy artillery and weapons
release all the hostages and launch the
political economic and humanitarian
process and we very happy that today
European Union demonstrate unity and the
solidarity with you played everybody
says that Georgia has made this
significant progress now it's about the
technical procedures to be completed and
I hope that this will be completed by
the end of this year so we expect to get
the visa-free regime by maybe next year
so therefore we stay committed and we
continue with our reforms pleased that
the declaration underlines the e youth
support to territorial integrity
independence and sovereignty of all the
Eastern Partnership countries it is very
important that in parallel to the
framework of political relations we also
promote economic trade and
people-to-people relations we are
heading for even greater mobility and
support for reforms there is
successfully operating visa-free regime
in place already with Moldova today I
would like to commend also antoje and
Ukraine that are actively working to
meet all the conditions in order to
receive a positive opinion from European
Commission that would be followed by the
decision about a visa-free regime this
message of our continued consistent and
strong commitment to the Eastern
Partnership and each of our partner
countries is the main message of the
summit and it is a necessary message in
light of the last year's turmoil
aggression intimidation and even war in
this part of Europe today we all
reaffirmed our common interest to
continue developing strengthened closer
differentiated relations with each of
our partners to help them become more
resilient in the face of increasing
challenges
to stability and security in the region
and to make sovereign choices
strengthened and more transparent
institutions free from corruption will
make our partner stronger and help us
maintain the Eastern Partnership
relevant fall since the Vilna family
have scientist oh she asian agreement
and deep and comprehensive free trade
areas with Georgia Moldova and Ukraine
this has brought our cooperation to a
new level we iterated our support to
others who are seeking more tailor-made
relations we have reached an
understanding with Armenia on the scope
of our future relationship we should
also be able to take some steps forward
in depending our critical engagement
with yellow rose and we have received
Azerbaijan suggestions regarding the
renewal of the contractual basis for its
relations with D you today we confirmed
our intention to make energy and
transport cooperation distinct
priorities for the coming years overall
we agreed to advance our cooperation in
those areas which bring tangible
benefits to our partner societies and
economies in particular and
state-building mobility and
people-to-people contacts market
opportunities and interconnections large
EOG in can often namaz ponder Georgia
and Ukraine have made enormous progress
in recent months today I was able to
hand over to the Georgian and Ukrainian
authorities a list of issues on which
George in Ukraine still need to make
some progress the Commission will be
publishing its next evaluation around
the 15 to December and then the council
would make the decision I'm very
optimistic about liberalizing visa
regimes for Ukraine and Georgia